. I have another great example for you from
Fox News.
In trying to keep the prop, the propaganda
narrative set by Donald Trump going.
Fox News brought on a doctor to talk about
chloroquine.
Unfortunately, they brought on the wrong doctor.
I think you're really going to like this.
This is an interview with Dr. William Haseltine.
William Haseltine was interviewed by Fox host
Dana Perino.
Dana Perino, you might remember, was George
W. Bush's press secretary at one point.
Haseltine is a well-known biologist, entrepreneur,
philanthropist.
He's a 75 year old guy now, did very important
work on HIV AIDS, did important work on the
human genome, taught at Harvard Medical School.
This is a serious guy.
He's serious in the medical world.
He's serious in the business world.
And he does not take Dana Perino's B.S. when
she now tries to keep pushing chloroquine
as a possible corona virus treatment, which
is exactly what Donald Trump has been doing.
Let's get to Dr. Haseltine starting to shut
down Dana Perino.
So can you tell me your thoughts about this
drug?
Everybody wants to find a cure or a treatment
or a therapy or a coronavirus.
What do you think about the drug that is used
normally to treat malaria?
Thank you for the question.
It saddens me that people are promoting my
drug.
We know already from studies at best it will
have a very mild effect at very best.
There are studies that can fix a little bit.
One from the other one concludes it has no
effect.
The other two close has a mild effect.
The net result is whatever effect it has.
It will be very mild.
That drug has been used for years against
many other viruses to know if.
They say that makes me sad about that story.
Some people may take it who are in early medications,
who were other underlying conditions, and
they have very serious life threatening consequences.
It is not something to take unless a doctor
prescribes it.
So notice that in 45 seconds he refutes just
about everything that Donald Trump has been
saying.
Trump says, what do you have to lose?
Dr. Haseltine explains.
You can lose your life.
It has life threatening side effects.
For some people, Trump says it's working really
well.
Dr. Haseltine explains there are conflicting
reports, but it is either mild or no impact.
And here Dana Perino continues pushing because
this is not going well to push Trump's narrative.
And now Dr. Haseltine straight up calls some
of the claims nonsense and says it is reminiscent
of quack cures when people continue to push
this.
And what about the I don't know, you don't
go by anecdotal evidence, but there are stories
of people saying.
They've had this Lazarus effect by using this
drug.
That is nonsense.
Complete and utter nonsense, and in any situation,
there are always going to be people who promote
one kind of quack cure or another.
And there are Lazaro's effects.
In every epidemic I've ever heard, it's always
the case.
Let me just repeat.
We know that at very best this drug will have
a very mild effect on changing the course
of disease.
If it has any effect at all.
That is what the data is showing so far, and
I am convinced it does what further studies
will show and is not without adverse consequences.
It is irresponsible to promote this drug at
this time in absolutely the most direct terms
so far.
A doctor on Fox News saying promoting this
like an exciting new product is irresponsible.
And Dana Perino simply unable to say much
else because she's not a doctor.
In the end, and she could only reference this
vague anecdotal evidence.
And that's another Fox News segment gone wrong
once again.
So you have to understand, Fox News is invested
in the Trump narrative when Trump was downplaying
Corona virus.
Fox was downplaying Corona virus when Trump
started using the word hoax in a coy way related
to coronavirus.
Fox News started using the word hoax.
Fox has been one of the biggest promoters
of chloroquine, allowing one hundred and nine
claims during a three day period in March
about how well the drug functions.
With only 15 claims during that same three
day period, which cast any doubt on the efficacy
of chloroquine to treat Corona virus, they
even bring on TV doctors, people very different
than Dr. Haseltine, including Dr. Oz to promote
chloroquine.
And so when we see a real doctor who is a
serious person smack down a Fox News host,
it is very entertaining.
But the most important thing is we don't go
any farther one way or the other than what
the science says.
Dr. Haseltine may be right.
It may have a small effect.
There are dozens of things being tested.
We should go through the process with everything
and not pick one drug to promote like a miracle
cure, which is what Donald Trump has been
doing.
If it turns out chloroquine, with or without
a zero myson, works well for certain patient
profiles, for example, or at certain stages
of the disease, that's great.
Remember, I've been talking about chloroquine
and as it throw myson much longer than Donald
Trump has.
But we've got to follow the science.
We can't turn this into a propaganda fest.
We don't pick a medication like a sports team
and promote it no matter what the facts are.
Good for Dr. Haseltine for setting Dr. Perino
straight.
I can't imagine he will be invited back on
the program.
We continue to cover the trials of various
medications on The David Pakman Show Instagram
page at David Tatem Show.
Make sure you're following.
You'll be back right after